(gentle music)
- Despite all the self-improvement
content that exists
on YouTube or online in general,
most people already know
exactly what they need to do
to improve their lives.
Pretty much every day we
have at least one thing
that we know we need to do
and if we were somehow
able to just sit down
and do that thing from start to finish,
our life would be better because of it.
You know, if you're a student,
maybe that's sitting down to
write a couple of hundred words
of that giant essay that you need to write
or maybe if you're just a regular guy
and you drive a 2005 Honda Civic
maybe it's making weird noises
and you really should
bring it into the shop
but for some reason, you're
not because it's working now.
So you assume it's gonna keep on working,
but you really should get it checked out.
It's not that people
don't know what to do,
that's not the problem.
The problem is that people
just don't do those things.
They put it off, they distract themselves.
They do pretty much
anything under the Sun,
even stuff that is sort
of vaguely important
in some way, but it's not
really important to you.
You might use that as
a justification like,
oh, I'm sweeping the floor
and that's productive
and you use that as an
excuse to not write the essay
even though the essay is
the most important thing
that you should be doing
and I don't wanna sound
like a boomer or anything like that,
but I actually think this
is becoming a bigger problem
that more and more people
are facing as time goes on
and that's because distracting
ourselves is easier
than it ever has been.
Every year, companies spend
billions upon billions
of dollars to shove ads
or products into your face
with online marketing that
nobody wanted or asked for.
You're just bombarded and
assaulted with all these
little pop-ups scattering your
attention and distracting you
from whatever you were
planning on doing when you sat
on the computer or opened
your phone or whatever.
Anyways I'll spare you all this woke talk
and just cut to the chase.
A world of distraction
simultaneously creates a huge demand
for people who can resist
its draw, or in other words,
the rarest and most important
skill you can cultivate
in today's information age is
the ability to concentrate.
The ability to actively
concentrate on one thing
for long periods of time
without getting distracted
isn't just one solution for
succeeding in the digital age,
it's the solution, but maybe
I'm not saying anything new.
You probably already know this.
It's not like some crazy
original idea that I've had
That if you can just focus
on doing important things
then you're gonna get better at life,
but like I said before, not
knowing what we need to do
isn't the problem,
it's the fact that we just don't do it.
Maybe you've tried to concentrate
for long periods of time
but you find it extremely,
almost pessimistically difficult
but that's exactly why
I'm making this video.
I'm probably the most distractable
person you've ever met.
Naturally, I'm very scatterbrained.
If a light turns on in the
other room, I'm like a moth,
I'm like, oh, what's that?
Let's go check it out.
In fact, my mom will tell you
I'm the worst procrastinator
she's ever raised but somehow
even I have managed to
find shortcuts and
strategies and little hacks
to convert myself into a
relatively productive human being
who can concentrate on boring things
for long periods of time.
It's a skill that anybody can learn
and one of the crazy things I've noticed
is that you don't need to
dive into like eight hours
of deep work in order to
make progress in your life.
The bar is actually way lower than that.
If you can dive in for one hour
on the most important thing
on your to-do list for the day
with a ruthless active concentration,
you will make substantial
progress in your life.
And as you get used to
putting in that hour of focus,
you can upgrade that to an
hour and a half, to two hours,
to three hours and even then, that's like,
that's so much intense focus
that you will skyrocket
past your goals and start
living a life that you actually
thought you'd be living at
this point in your life,
let's be real.
So I'm gonna break this video
down into three categories.
Step one is to properly craft
your physical environment.
(gentle piano music)
You probably heard it a million times
that if you have a messy room,
then you're gonna have a messy mind
and if you just clean
and organize your room,
it's kind of like cleaning
and organizing your mind.
There's an amazing truth to this.
Even if you just look at it
from a practical perspective,
each room should have a
use and each physical space
where you dwell should reduce the friction
that's in the way of doing the things
that that room was
intended to help you do.
So for instance, in my own home office,
I have a video editing PC.
It's where I do all my creative stuff,
it's where I'm shooting this video,
behind me, whoops, right there.
If I want to help myself
succeed and to concentrate
and not get distracted,
I should clean my desk
to be as minimal as possible.
The only things on there should
help me accomplish my tasks
that I've been setting out to do.
This might sound like a
total sidetrack rabbit hole,
I promise it'll make sense in a second.
So I bought one of these
awesome little wireless chargers
for my phone.
I bought it off Amazon, it was sleek,
it was sexy, kind of fake wood.
And I figured, hey, this
would be a great addition
to my desk.
I can put my phone on there,
I can see when I'm getting
notifications and I'll never run
out of juice on my phone
throughout the day.
But if you think about it,
that's a really stupid idea.
Why do I need to be notified
when somebody is texting me
or somebody comments on
something on the Facebook page
or something like that?
I'm literally inviting more
distraction into my life
and it's dumb.
So how did I get around this?
Well, there's a little
shelf next to me, this one
and I just put my wireless
phone charger there, behind me
so that when I'm video
editing into a flow state
and it doesn't distract me.
Little fixes like this seem really small
and you might think, oh, Joey,
you're making like a 15-minute video
about little dumb tricks like this?
Yes.
Believe me, when it comes to
your focus, it is everything
and this doesn't just
apply to the workspace too.
There are other little ways
that your environment dictates
the amount of focus that you have.
So for instance, if you
usually keep your phone
on your nightstand next to your bed,
then that's kind of dumb
if your plan for that room
is to go to sleep.
So I personally found that I
was spending way too much time
on my phone before I went to sleep
and it was becoming a real problem
and it was affecting my sleep
and I couldn't get into a deep sleep,
so I woke up in the morning
feeling really groggy
all the time, every single day.
So what I did is I bought a
cheap little Google Nest Mini
and I leave my phone on a charging station
outside of my bedroom and it's great.
Every night I say, okay Google
set an alarm for 8:00 AM.
- [Google] Tomorrow at 8:00 AM, set.
- Thank you, Google.
Goodnight.
Goodnight Google.
All right, that's okay.
You don't need to say it back.
So, your bedroom is for sleeping.
Your office is for working.
Your kitchen is for cooking,
your private bowling alley in
your basement is for bowling.
(upbeat music)
Okay, moving on to section two,
this is all about designing
your digital environment.
Just like your physical environment,
it is integral that you design
your digital environment
to also promote focus.
You know, I'm not Thomas
Frank, but I do have a couple
of sleeves, sleeves up my trick.
I have a couple of tricks
up my sleeve that helped me,
helped me focus on stuff.
Here's a bunch of things
that helped me focus online.
So a lot of these are Chrome extensions,
I think they're available
for Firefox as well.
So number one is to download
NewsFeed Eradicator for Facebook
and what this does is it
replaces your Facebook home page
with a motivational quote
and it gets rid of you
scrolling everywhere.
So if you actually do stumble on Facebook,
especially when you're working,
all there really is to
do is see if you have
any notifications or respond to messages.
You won't get caught in the
trap of just like absorbing
all this meaningless hotel
nightmares, kitchen nightmares,
is hotel nightmares one?
Another awesome Chrome
extension and I think it's also
for Firefox as well is DF YouTube
which stands for distraction-free YouTube.
Shout out to my friend, Alex
for showing me this one.
If you're like me, YouTube is probably
the biggest time suck of all,
but what DF YouTube does is it eliminates
the classic homepage
so you're not bombarded
with all these huge thumbnails
of all these different recommended videos.
It just wipes it clean.
You know, you still get the trending tab,
if you're into that kind of thing,
I don't know who would be,
probably just like Lele Pons
and the Late Night Hosts.
My favorite part about it is it also
keeps the subscriptions
tab so that the people
you're actually subscribed
to show up there.
Another thing that it does is
that it actually eliminates
the sidebar of all
these recommended videos
so that when you're watching
the video of the channel
that you actually meant to watch,
you're not sucked into
watching another channel
and you know, you go down the rabbit hole.
You're just intentionally watching
what you set out to watch.
Another thing I did, this is
a little bit more extreme,
but it worked really well
for me is that I deleted
social media apps off my phone in general
and when I want to use a particular app,
I actually have to physically type it in
on Safari or whatever.
Okay, section number three,
this is all about training your mind.
(upbeat music)
Sorry, that's probably a bit much.
The first two sections
were all about eliminating
little traps and attention
sucking succubuses
but this whole section is all
about developing a philosophy
and a mindset of intentionality.
And this is one of the most important
and powerful mindsets you can adopt
to promote concentration.
You need to train your
mind to be more intentional
with your time, and you might
think I'm coming at this
from a hustle culture
perspective where every single
ounce of your time needs to be dedicated
to working on your craft or
grinding or something like that,
but that's actually, I
don't believe that at all.
You know, for instance, I
am a big fan of video games.
I think video games are a
great way to take a breather
and escape and engage
with either a work of art
or a multiplayer experience,
(beep)
but my point is, if you're
gonna play video games,
play the crap out of video
games for like an hour or two
after you've already put in
the tremendous amount of focus
on something else, you've been productive,
you've put in your time, you
were intentional with it,
so that you can fully immerse
yourself in a video game
with no guilt.
Being present and fully engaged
with whatever you're doing,
whether that's having
fun, having a conversation
with a friend, whether
it's working on something
extremely creative and fulfilling,
I feel like this is the key to
a happy and fulfilling life.
One of the best ways that you can develop
more intentionality in your
life in order to promote focus
but also just to have a more
fulfilling life in general
is to create a schedule for your day
and a schedule shouldn't
be seen as something
like the super ruthless
iron-fisted limiting concoction
that you trap and imprison
yourself into fulfilling,
your schedule is your own.
You can design your day in a
way that is fulfilling to you.
You know, before you design your schedule,
you can really ask yourself
what could I do day to day
that I would truly feel
happy and fulfilled with?
How much time would I dedicate to working
and be realistic with that?
How much time should I
dedicate to socializing
and be realistic?
If gaming is important to
you or something like that,
or working out or whatever,
you have the freedom
to design your day in a way
that's most fulfilling to you.
But once you do that,
be absolutely ruthless
with being engaged and intentional
with every single thing
on your schedule.
That way when you're working,
you get way more work done
because you're concentrated,
when you're playing
you have a lot more fun
because you're right
there, not guiltily playing
because you didn't actually do work
and you shouldn't actually be playing
and to develop focus specifically,
start off by scheduling
one hour of focus on
a very specific thing that
you really need to get done.
Pretty much everyone can manage one hour,
once they enter a flow state,
you know, try to break
past that 20 minute mark,
so you can enter that flow state.
And after a couple of weeks
of getting used to doing
an hour of deep focus, ramp
it up to an hour and a half,
then to two hours, maybe
two and a half hours,
three, if it's, you know,
if you're really getting
the hang of it, I find that
three hours is sort of the point
of time that I'm the most productive
and after that, it's sort
of diminishing returns.
And as you get better at developing
the skill of concentration,
you'll find that
you get stuff done a lot quicker.
You know, you only put
three hours into work
and you're really concentrated
and you can get more
done in those three hours
than you typically did in
your entire week.
If you have a high intensity workout,
you can usually spend
that hour and a half,
you spend at the gym checking your phone
and taking 10 minute recipe four sets,
you can reduce that
time to like 45 minutes,
so basically you free up
all this time in your day
for something else.
And if you're looking for
another something else,
then I'd highly recommend
checking out my boy,
Thomas Frank's brand
new class on Skillshare,
all about developing habits.
A big thank you to Skillshare
for sponsoring this video.
Skillshare is an online
learning community that offers
membership with meaning,
with so much to explore,
real projects to create
and the support of fellow creatives,
Skillshare empowers you
to accomplish real growth.
Skillshare offers classes
designed for real life,
so you can move your
creative journey forward
without putting your life on hold.
You can learn and grow with short classes
that fit your busy schedule.
Thomas Frank's first class
is a productivity masterclass
fits the digital environment
topic of today's video
quite well so I would also
highly recommend checking out
that one as well and the awesome thing is
all these classes I'm talking about,
and then I'm recommending, you
can check out today for free.
If you click the link in the description,
it gives you two months
of Skillshare premium,
absolutely free and after that,
it's still extremely affordable.
If you pay for the annual membership,
it comes in at less than $10 a month.
So once again, click the
link in the description
to get two months of Skillshare
premium absolutely free
and explore your creativity.
If you liked this video,
make sure to hit like,
because when you hit like,
the algorithm blesses me
and it shoves this video in
front of other people's faces,
helping them out and it also helps me out,
so it's a complete win-win
for everybody involved.
If you like videos like this in general,
definitely hit subscribe
and hit the bell icon
so that you don't miss
future videos that I put out.
I actually just created a second channel.
So I'm gonna put the
link in the description
for that as well.
I wanna upload more regularly,
but a usual better ideas
video definitely takes
a lot of time and effort.
So it's not like I can be
posting these every single day
even though I want to be,
so that's why I created a second channel
for more off the cuff Mimi stuff,
I'll, you know, I'll do live streams,
maybe I'll start a podcast on there,
click the link in the
description to subscribe
to the second channel
and I think it will be,
I'm sure, I know,
I know it'll be an awesome time
but anyways, that is all for today.
I'm really excited about the next video,
so yeah, we'll see you in that one, later.
(gentle music)